if you could go in and Tinker with the
current world of men's dating advice
what would be the main lessons that you
would try to dispense with talk about
commitment more and be very clear about
what you want every woman who comes into
my dating practice is scared to death to
say I just want to find one man to marry
and have children with and be with for
the rest of my life but if I mention
that to any man before year three he is
going to get up and run screaming from
me and the men who come into my coaching
practice say I just want one woman to be
with for the rest of my life and have
children but if I mention that before
year three she will think I'm a psycho
who's trying to control her men it makes
you so attractive when you are very
clear what you want but you must
understand that you also have to pass
tests that prove that that is actually
what you want you must prove that you
are a man of substance who is out there
to make change in the world any kind of
change and who is reliable and
consistent so that you could be
dependent upon in a family situation